هذان الابوان رزقا بثلاثه عشر ابنا وابنه
كانوا يعيشون جميعا في منزل يبدو عاديا من
الخارج في مدينه بيريس جنوب شرقي لوس
انجلوس الى ان جاءت اللحظه التي كشف فيها
عن جحيم مخفي خلف جدران ذلك المنزل
الاسم ديفيد
التهمه الاحتجاز والتعذيب المكان
كاليفورنيا الولايات المتحده الحكم السجن
مدى الحياه
في يناير عام 2018 تلقت شرطه مدينه بيريس
اتصالا من فتاه تستغيث وتطلب النجده
الفتاه كانت واحده من ابناء ديفيد توربين
البالغ من العمر حينها 57 عاما وزوجته
الويز البالغه 49 عاما وتمكنت الفتاه من
الهروب من نافذه في منزل العائله عند وصول
الشرطه تفاجات بحال الفتاه البالغه من
العمر حينها 17 عاما اذ كانت تعاني من سوء
تغذيه شديد لدرجه ان الشرطه اعتقدت انها
طفله بعمر العشر سنوات لكن الصدمه الكبرى
جاءت بعد دخول بيت العائله منزل مظلم
وموحش تنبعث منه رائحه كريهه عثرت فيه
الشرطه على 12 اخا واختا كانوا مقيدين
بالاغلال والسلاسل وكانوا جميعا يعانون من
حاله مزريه وقذاره شديده وسوء تغذيه حاده
والمفاجاه ان سبعه منهم كانوا بالغين
وتترا اعمارهم بين 18
و29 عاما
القي القبض على الابوين وتبين من خلال
التحقيقات وشهاده ابنائهما ان اثني عشر
منهم تعرضوا للاحتجاز وسوء التغذيه
والاعتداء الجسدي فيما لم تظهر علامات سوء
المعامله على اصغر فرد في الاسره البالغ
من العمر سنتين حينها الابواني كان يجوعان
ابناءهما عمدا ويطعمانهم وجبه واحده فقط
في اليوم ويسمحان لهم بالاستحمام مره في
السنه
وغالبا يقيدون الابناء الى اسرتهم كعقاب
لعده اسابيع واحيانا للشهور ولا يسمحان
لهم في بعض الاحيان حتى بالذهاب الى دوره
المياه
بعد سماع شهاده الابناء في المحكمه تم
توجيه اربعه عشره تهمه الى الزوجين تشمل
الاحتجاز والتعذيب والتجويع وسوء المعامله
اقرت ثنائي بذنبهما وتقدما باعتذار من
ابنائهما قائلين انما فعلاه بهم كان بنيه
حسنه
فلكل ما اقترفته بحق اطفالي احب اطفالي
كثيرا وانا محظوظه كوني امم لكل واحد منهم
سعادتهم مهمه جدا بالنسبه لي اريدهم ان
يعرفوا ان امهم واباهم سيكونان على ما
يرام
في العشرين من ابريل عام 2019 انقلب السحر
على الساحر وتحول ديفيد والويز من سجانين
الى سجانين بعد ان حكم عليهما بالسجن مدى
الحياه مع امكانيه طلب اطلاق سراح مبكر
بعد خمسه وعشرين عاما من السجن اما
الابناء فبداوا حياه جديده بعيده عنك
كابوس منزل السلاسل